Okay, thanks everyone. So this is the follow-up on the entity replace and upgrade rules. I sent the summary document on Wednesday, did you get it?
Yep, got it, read it. So that one's done as far as I'm concerned, the summary is there.
Yes, I have it too. Before we go through it, can we close out a couple of things from Monday first?
Sure. So I went through the METCO bill. We are paying for forty two services on the tagged template and none on PRIORITY-MARK mapped. So it is only tagged, forty two of them. I sent the list to Rafael this morning.
Yes, I received it, thank you Marty.
Good, so that action is closed. And on the CR, I have put the tagged mode support on the CR list, and the business have asked for the options and the vendor estimate before they decide, so that one is in progress, it is with Rafael for the estimate now.
Correct, I will have the estimate for the forty two tagged services by next week.
And the port default. I took the one port or four port question to the business on Tuesday and they decided to keep one port as the default. They do not want to change what we send to customers. So that is decided, we keep one port.
Good, that is the right call, that is what we do today anyway.
Okay, so the default stays one port, and we do not need the four port default rule. Noted.
Now on the capacity of the GEN-1, I checked the METCO specification. The GEN-1 ACCESS-TYPE-A is 1.3 gig downstream and the GEN-1 ACCESS-TYPE-B is 1 gig downstream. So it is confirmed, it is in the spec, page twelve.
Yep, I have the same spec open, 1.3 and 1 gig. Confirmed.
And I asked NETCO about the connect outstanding. They came back and said connect outstanding allows an entity replace for both ACCESS-TYPE-A and ACCESS-TYPE-B, because the premises may have an old device left behind by the previous occupant. So it is both, not only ACCESS-TYPE-B.
Makes sense. So that question is answered then.
Now the charge risk you raised, Marty, the three hundred dollar one. What we propose is that whenever the entity selection lands on a chargeable add or replace, the orchestration flow will stop and raise a manual task for approval before the order goes to METCO. So nothing chargeable goes out automatically.
Yes, that is what I want. A manual approval step on anything chargeable. Then we are not burning revenue by accident.
Agreed, let us review that risk again at the end of the month once the flow is designed.
Okay. And the entity selection rule itself, Elena, Marty, did you get a chance to walk through the summary? We still need your approval on that one.
Not yet, Marty and I will walk through it on Monday and come back to you. So that stays open, next step is our walkthrough.
Okay, no problem. Thanks everyone, see you Monday.
Cheers, bye.